okay welcome to the ddps seminar
everyone below uh before uh we introduce
our invited speaker let's go over some
rules and Logistics first of all uh
please mute yourself during the talk uh
but if you have questions you can unmute
and ask questions or use chat room to
post your questions so that we can
address them in Q&A session at the end
second today's ddps seminar is open to
external audience uh therefore no
classified discussion is allowed so
please watch out finally The Talk today
will be recorded and uploaded in our
YouTube channel that's about it uh now
now let me briefly introduce our speaker
today it is an honor to host Dr Gian
Luca yino who is the director of The
Institute for computational mathematical
engineering and a professor in the
mechanical engineering department at
Stanford University he received his PhD
in Italy from the polych uh Poly
Technical D Bari um before joining The
Faculty at Stanford in 2010 uh 2007
since 2014 he is the director of the
peap center at Stanford funded by the US
Department of energy focused on multif
physics simulation uncertainty
quantification and exess scale Computing
he received the presidential Oly career
award for scientists and engineer years
award and he is a fellow of APs today
Jan luuka will talk about Auto encoders
for aerodynamic predictions which is a
exciting topic so please expect a
wonderful talk from him now let me ask a
question to Gian Luca if that is okay
with you is it okay asking you one
question absolutely okay yes okay in
audience there are many students and O
career researchers to this ddps seminar
uh who are currently working on
computational and data science if you
give them some sort of career advice
what kind of advice would you
provide that's a that's a great question
as a start um I I I'll say something
that I tell most of the students that
pass through through icme and through
Stanford which is um everything that
that you do in research should be driven
by C I it you should be really have uh
open mind in terms of uh asking
questions um and and I think that should
be a real passion uh in the sense that
it should be a natural tendency to sort
of be curious and and try to get to the
bottom of what is that you're seeing why
it's happening and that Curiosity can
really drive you to give to get sort of
a a a a learning in in terms of the work
that you're doing that can be really
very very powerful so curiosity as a as
a m main driver in what we do in
research is is critical absolutely thank
you thank you so much for the the
wonderful answer okay the stage is
yours thank you very much uh thank you
uh for for the invitation and uh uh
thank you for joining um my as I
mentioned as as was mentioned I I'm
going to talk about out and corders uh I
wasn't sure about again the the
composition of the audience so this talk
is going to be uh relatively high level
to give you some of the basic ideas of
of the work that we have been doing and
I'm happy to discuss this in more
details either during the Q&A or maybe
afterwards you can feel free to reach me
uh if you have if you have questions so
um the first thing I want to say is that
uh um my uh presentation is going to be
a little bit different than what I
typically do in uh uh in my daily work
as as was mentioned I'm the director of
the peace up Center at Stanford and this
is actually a slide that represents the
work that we're doing in that Center has
to do with um ignition laser induced
ignition of uh uh rocket engines uh
you're seeing a a a a steel uh
visualization and then animation of the
combustion process and we're working on
um exascale Computing platforms to do
the simulations at scale there is a
component of this project that has to do
with uh machine learning and a certainty
quantification that obviously connect
the the uh presentation today but I'm
not going to really give you any details
of this work if you're interested again
I'm I would be very happy to to discuss
it um afterwards um and so instead today
what I want to tell you is really a
story uh about a project that I started
when I was in sabatical a couple of
years ago now three years ago um and
started really as a curiosity try to
learn more about some of these um
algorithm that we all hear a lot about
um and uh uh the project Revol around
aerodynamics which is sort of the work I
was doing at the time and uh a specific
class of algorithms that many of you
might be familiar with but to sort of
introduce them I'll I'll sort of use a
very very sort of simple um uh simple
connection to tools that instead we use
perhaps uh every day in our life you
know the the the simplest uh uh approach
that you can think of in in this real is
jzip jzip is as you familiar with is a
compression to tool allows you to take a
big file and reduce its size um and it's
a relatively straightforward and
relatively uh innocent tool is actually
very sophisticated very effective um and
it's what What's called the lossless
direct compression so allows you to go
one way uh meaning from the original
file to the compressed file but also
come back with the exact reconstruction
of the original file okay if you want to
uncompress it or unzip it now this is as
I said a a tool that we're all familiar
with perhaps another tool that is uh
again in the in the same spirit so a
compression tool but that many of you
might be familiar with from perhaps U um
application is the singular value de
composition a singular value DEC
composition is again typical s similar
compression tool where you start from an
object in this case an image it can be a
different uh it might not be necessarily
an image but perhaps a matrix or just a
file and the idea is that you take this
image and you compress it reduce its
size by um performing a matrix
decomposition in in in in terms of
linear algebra and this Matrix
decomposition leads you to a reduced
representation in this case that uh has
a effective size that's about one10 of
it um and the advantage with respect to
the previous tool is that it has a
tunable parameter which is the number of
singular value that you preserve this is
the amount of compression that you forc
in the algorithm and as you reduce that
number in this case it's 30 singular
values if you reduce it to six or even
lower to one obviously you obtain a much
more compressed representation but
obviously also you lose information
you're not representing that uh original
object in the same way but again you you
achieve a very high level of compression
now the problem with this is that this
is a a compression that is that is lossy
in the sense that you're losing
information and doesn't allow you to go
back to the original version of the
image but it is a very powerful uh
method is actually used you know in
almost every um uh algorithm that has to
do with large uh large data set at least
in a linear sense and it provides you
what um is can be referred to as a
latent representation the singular value
as sort of a new representation of the
original data that has captur of the
features some of the character of the
original image now what I want to talk
about today is actually a version of
this process which is based on machine
learning which is the the basis of an
out encoder an out encoder is a
compression algorithm very similar to
what I described before but it's a much
more powerful because of the uh of the
um uh generality of the the
representation that it uses allows you
to take again now not just one image but
perhaps a large number of images in this
case uh mnes is a classical um uh
database a classical test set for for
machine learning that includes 70,000
images so a very large uh amount of data
in this case equivalent pixel is sort of
a representation of how much data we
have and allows you to actually uh uh
compress it in a very reduced form and
and regenerate some of the um uh images
or perhaps generate a large set of
images based on again a representation
in terms of feature that is very very
compressed in this case with only two
latent variables we are able to actually
reproduce the entire data set in a in a
sort of a relatively uh effective and
accurate way again it's similar to
before is a lossy compression it cannot
really reconstruct exactly the original
images but it is very powerful and and
is based on a representation that uses
nonlinearity as opposed to SVD that
instead only uses linear operations so
what I want to talk to you today is
really um AO encoders apply to
aerodynamics again I don't know how much
you are familiar with aerodynamics but
uh this is a typical application of of
uh in the aerodynamic context this is
flow over a a um full uh uh aeronautic
configuration a a um a typical test case
in uh in aerodynamic analysis um and
today we can do this simulation fairly
effectively uh and accurately so we can
actually reproduce for example the lift
characteristics of of a full uh airplane
very accurately all the way uh from low
angle of attack to high angle of attack
which is the the angle the incidence
that the air the the airplane has with
the incoming flow um and the prediction
in this case can be run on a large scale
system in this case Summit about 100
gpus with a uh relatively small uh uh
wall clock time so with with good good
turnaround um now unfortunately although
this is the state of the art and we are
very very um uh we can predict very
accurately what happens in the physics
the problem is that we can still we are
still Limited in the number of
calculations we can do for example for
design and so the the idea is to try to
use knowledge and and these methods like
how encoders and other compression
strategy to build databases of these Cal
ation and then perhaps generate new
cases that have not been directly
simulated through um through H
simulation so that's sort of the the
reason why we started this project to
try to build tools that allow you to
take some of these data sets and
compress it and allow it to generate
additional additional data additional
information so just to to uh summarize
sort of what we typically do in
aerodynamic simulation in all physics
simulations uh this is sort of the
process we start from uh basic
principles we build a conceptual model
which is a set of PDs typically we
cannot really obtain Solutions directly
and so we go through a discretization
and a computational algorithm to
actually find an approximate solution
and we use superc computers to solve the
corresponding uh numerical uh
computational problem that emerges from
that algorithm and that allows us to
actually compute compute the the
quantity of interest and the solution we
care about and the the point I want to
make here is that this is a a a typical
uh deduction process that we follow from
Theory to actual data so the the
framework is generic is general and the
uh example that we obtain is actually
one specific instance of the
solution now the the other thing I want
to and then I'll stop in terms of the
physics of the problem at least in
general is that I'm going to show you
results for two different scenarios the
first is when we actually operate the um
uh an F in this case or you can think of
it as a wing of the airplane um in a
steady fashion as we change the angle of
attack we obtain a curve which is the
blue one here which sort of represents
the fact that for low angle of attack
the behavior is basically linear the
lift increases with the angle of attack
in a linear fashion and then it reaches
a limit which is a sto where the the
phenomenon becomes nonlinear and the
lift starts decreasing now a different
story which I which I also use to
illustrate the results here is what
happens when you have an unsteady motion
so the the airfall goes to a a periodic
motion of changing a Neal attack but you
see that the behavior in this case is
the black curve here is similar in the
sense that you have a a linear increase
of the lift and then eventually the the
lift drops and you have this sort of
unsteady behavior that then turns back
into into the uh the the low angle of
attack as you sort of oscillate between
positive and negative angle of attack so
I'm going to show you these two regimes
because um the both the the steady and
unsteady results to illustrate the power
of some of the methodology that I'll
I'll describe
afterwards um so let's let's talk about
machine learning now in in a general
setting compared to what I shared to you
before the approach is very different in
this case we don't start from first
principles from physical understanding
and conceptual model we actually start
from data from examples we build a
statistical representation of the data
that can be very sophisticated or uh um
you know in a sense relatively simple
then we train the model in this case we
actually compute the parameters
corresponding to that statistical model
and then we are able to uh for example
recognize uh classify the images that we
get so the data the examples we get or
perhaps produce new new examples uh I to
trivialize this um the simplest example
of data driven model is regression in a
regression setting we assume a function
that represents the data at least that
we believe represents the data in this
case a quadratic function and the
objective of the algorithm is to find
the coefficients a0 A1 A2 that
approximate or minimize the
approximation error with respect to the
data of this model with respect to the
data once we have completed that that
process which obviously is the uh the
training phase in a in a machine
learning paraland then we have a method
and approach that allows us to generate
new data meaning that with the new X we
can compute that new F ofx which
represents Now new data that is unseen
that is not being part of the training
so this is the simplest model obviously
the models we de typically deal with and
in particular the models that I'll talk
about have millions of parameters order
10 million parameters they're much more
complicated than a quadratic function
they're still no linear but obviously
have much more complexity embedded in it
but in principle I have the same spirit
in the sense that you start from initial
guesses of this parameter then use the
data to actually learn what the best fit
and the best parameters will
be uh from the process that I described
this is actually an induction process so
we go from data to an actual theory in
quote obviously it's not a theory per se
but gives you sort of the sense that we
don't start from assuming uh knowledge
of the problem necessarily we start from
example and we try to build a knowledge
uh uh a posterior
and and so to illustrate this the
simplest example that we started from
was a database of flow geometries this
is an example that you see in literature
these days there have been many U uh
similar sort of applications in this
case the the geometries are very simple
they're Bluff bodies just you know uh
two-dimensional Bluff bodies and the and
these are represented in the first
columns here the first and third columns
they're basically just a a
representation of the geometry and the
second column is actually the velocity
distribution uh so red implies low
velocity the wake and then the flow
around this geometry is captured through
velocity magnitude now if you pass these
images very much like we pass the uh M
the the digits uh in the in the original
example we can actually then build a
representation where we can accurately
predict what happens around uh new cases
geometries that have not been part of
the database and everything looks
reasonable in this case um you can
actually show that uh uh the true
solution actually is close to the
predicted solution you can quantify the
errors and so on and so forth and and it
seems like everything seems to be pretty
trivial now again talking about the the
answer I gave before curiosity right
this seems to be all done well the the
uh first thing we tried is to push the
algorithm and see what happens if you do
something a little bit different that
was not anticipated when you built this
and the simplest thing I could think of
is what happens if you have multiple
bodies so rather than one now I give the
outter encoder more geometries so in
this case again the training was done
before with single bodies and I'm asking
the out encoder to uh extract a new data
set now on a geometry that is completely
different completely outside of the
scope now if you look at the results
here and you know that that was the part
that was uh interesting to us it's very
difficult to now obviously you know this
is the prediction so you you might argue
we don't know if it's accurate or not we
could compute the true solution but just
looking at it you actually cannot tell
if this solution is right or wrong it's
very reasonable it's you know seems to
be capturing the fact that there is some
interaction between these objects again
it's not something that was coded
already in the training set but it seems
to be reasonable and looking at the true
solution there is clearly some
discrepancies but they they're not you
know completely
off right so the the interesting thing
here is that the uh the idea is we
wanted to perhaps uh break the algorithm
and at first glance is difficult to
guess if the algorithm was actually
broken or not um and and so this sort of
stimulated the question of how can we
build confidence in these algorithms so
that the results that we obtain are
actually results that we can interpret
even in the absence of the true output
right in some cases we don't want to be
need to compute the output every time we
want to check the solution so how can we
build automatically confidence in the
prediction of these methods and so this
how the the entire project started and
how we sort of trying to go to a method
where uh we build some a process in the
construction of this outen Cod that
allows us to really interpret the
results of the of the uh process in a
way that is informing the confidence we
have in the
output so just to to um uh sort of
summarize what the out encoder is as I
mentioned is is a compression technique
uh the basic idea is that you are trying
to to build an algorithm that reproduces
the input so you the input and the
output are basically the same the same
information and you're going through a
bottleneck you're basically
compressing the information to uh to as
smallest possible set which is sort of
this red bottleneck in the middle which
is sort of U uh called in in the in the
uh machine learning par the Lattin space
the Latin Vector um and the user
controls the compression uh compression
um size right so like in the SVD you you
control how many um uh singular value
you you retain uh to represent the rank
of the problem in this case you keep a
certain size for this latent Vector uh
the way we construct the out encoder is
that we include both convolutional
layers and um and fully connected layers
uh the reason is because physically we
expect the input to be uh aerodynamic
flow Fields so we want to make sure that
there is invariance that is embedded
into into the network and also coupling
between information in the data that we
are providing and so we have we kept
both a convolutional uh a set of
convolutional layer and set of coupling
layers uh and there are obviously many
variants in the literature of the outen
coders I'll tell you a little bit of the
flavor that we are using but we have
done extensive comparison also to other
type of outen coders that I won't
discuss here um but I'm happy to again
uh discuss it in more in more details so
specifically in the way we built this
framework we want it to be very
principled in the way we actually
approach the problem and so there are
effectively four steps the first step is
the construction of the database um and
the the second is the actual training so
the the uh machine learning training of
this network the third is what we call
latent space conditioning and and is a
way to map the uh database inputs to the
latent Vector uh that is done after the
training so this is a um a step that
does not affect the training itself and
then finally once you have completed
this you have now a methodology that
allows you to do predictions meaning
that you can uh uh generate new
geometries or new problems uh and and
create uh Solutions out of that and
typically only this only involves the
decoder so the second part of the of the
uh Network that we have we have
constructed so just to give you a little
bit more details of exactly what what
we're talking about the the first step
is to actually the construction of the
database what we have done in these
problems is to build databases of airf
geometries um at uh different geometries
different iall thickness for different e
attack and typically we uh limit the
number of cases quite substantially so
we typically have an order of 30 or so
cases um to do the entire process so
we're not uh talking about extensive
data sets and the reason is because
eventually we want to move towards very
high fidelity uh data sets and so we are
expecting that order of 100 is really
the limit of what you can generate both
in terms of uh computational costs but
also in terms of
storage um there are some details of how
the actual data sets are are um uh
transferred to the to the uh machine
learning tools so basically how we
organize the database that I can talk
more about it in in the in the uh at the
end but in general we do need to build a
representation that is amable to to a
machine learning tool so we have to
summarize these data sets into uh
basically a single vector or basically a
single tensor that captures the solution
in uh in space but also in terms of
different variables for example density
momentum temperature and so
on now the the training itself is a uh I
mentioned already is an autoencoder uh
we typically because of the limited data
set that we use limited size of data set
we have also a relatively small number
of parameters order 10 Millions um and a
very very small latent Dimension this is
this has been our goal to sort of make
sure that the latent space is as small
as possible um and uh uh for example
this is an a learning um uh a Lo a loss
function for um uh for um for our
problem for this problem that mention
that I'm mentioning here at uh different
values of the latent space different
sizes of Lent space so as you can see
for P1 and P equal 2 effectively the um
the loss function stalls uh does not
really uh decrease anymore after uh
about 500 EPS whereas uh as you increase
the the the latent size the um um the
loss function uses a little bit more uh
although effectively after three four
and five at three four and five
effectively reach the same level of
convergence and effectively the out and
coders perform in the same way meaning
that uh a dat in size of three for
example two or three is sufficient
actually to summarize and compress the
information that we are giving the
reactivity out coder at least with a
fixed
architecture now let me say a few words
about the mapping the uh latent space
conditioning so the basic idea is that
the outen coder only has access to the
flow Fields the entire solution but
doesn't know anything about how that
solution has been generated what are the
inputs for that for that uh particular
uh data set that we're considering and
so what we are doing in this case is
that we are actually building a mapping
between the true inputs so for example
the angle of attack and the latent
Dimension the latent uh vectors uh the
latent uh quantities so this is a
typical example of this of this mapping
where we have an out encoder of size
three so three latent variables and what
we do is that we map the two inputs of
the database in this case the thickness
and the angle of attack these are all
the solution that we generate to build a
database onto the latent value Ables and
and this allows us then to uh go from
the input variable to the latent
variables and then eventually to through
the decoder through the actual uh
solution uh synthetic solution or the
the reconstructed Solutions and so just
to um complete then once you have this
map this conditioning or this mapping
between the input and the latent
variables then you can really generate
new Solutions and uh because you can uh
extract for example a new um uh air for
at a given thickness for all the angle
of attack and then you can build an
actual solution and this is an example
of of this case of this dyamic Soul case
where the airf is oscillating uh at
different angle of attack and this shows
the comparison of the Mac number one of
the quantity of Interest comparing the
actual solution the cfd will be the true
the true solution that again is not uh
um used in this case um and the
synthetic solution which is the result
of the outen coder now in this actually
this particular case the Naka 002 was in
the training data set so this is one of
the cases that has been seen by the by
the um out encoder um but you can do the
same thing with a case that has not been
seen so this is the NAA 0020 is beyond
sort of the scope of the database or the
the training set and the results again
are are reasonable so what you're seeing
again is the comparison of the synthetic
and the true solution now we can argue
if the results are actually as accurate
as possible and and so on but remember
that my goal here was not necessarily to
get the best possible out encoder but to
try to understand if we can build
confidence in these results and so I'll
I'll actually start going in that
direction by explaining or trying to um
illustrate what is the out qu learning
so the first thing to to keep in mind is
what is the physical behavior that we
expect and this I showed you this before
these curves before uh this is uh
effectively the main quantity of
interest for different angle of attack
what is the lift coefficient generated
by different airs and what you're seeing
here is the linear regime a low angle of
attack where actually all the the airs
behave in the same way they have exactly
the same lift coefficient and then
things change when you reach the sto
where the effect of the thickness of the
airfall actually is is clear here and so
the the first question is um are we
actually able to distinguish between
this linear and nonlinear Behavior
within the latent space that the outon
coder is recognizing again remember that
we're not giving the outon coder the um
knowledge of this quantity we are just
giving the flow field to the out encoder
to compress well it turns out if we
actually look at at what's happening um
actually let me skip this um let me go
directly to this um if we show if we
look at the latent space in this case
for a AO encoder with Dimension two so
even smaller than what I was describing
before this is what the latent space
looks like like these are the variable
V1 and V2 the two latent variables and
this is now colored in terms of the
thickness of the air flow but also in
terms of the angle of attack in the
sense that you see that for low angle of
attack we have actually a linear
Behavior a linear correlation between V1
and V2 the latent space is very well
sort of ordered very um uh neatly spaced
um and it sort of represents the linear
and nonlinear behavior in a in a
relatively straightforward fashion you
see that there are obviously more
complexity when the angle of attack
increases but you still see a very clean
difference between all the the airfall
thickness so you can easily imagine that
you can go back from this latent space
to any uh airfall either within these
airfall that we actually included in the
database or outside there is a very
clear way to sort of build a a broader
set of
solutions now the the the thing that is
that again drives that drove my
curiosity in this case is okay this is
an out encoder with P equal 2 which
seems to be reasonable what happens if P
equal 1 if I try to compress it even
more now the expectation is that if I
compress it even more it shouldn't work
because I do have at least two degree of
freedom in the original database that I
built thickness angle a to and and so P
equal one should fail well it turns out
it does fail but fails in a very you
know acceptable and interpretable way so
what happens is that if I only have one
latent variable P equal 1 V1 and I try
to uh compare it to the angle of attack
see what happens in terms of the angle
of attack what I see is that for low
angle of attack effectively
V1 uh shows a single curve that is
linear behavior and correspondingly I
know that there is no effect of the
thickness and so effectively is able to
compress it up to a certain angle of
attack because it's true that for low
angle of attack the out should be able
to compress those solution very
effectively as we increase the angle of
attack now the second variable the
second degree of Freedom starts to
become important and in fact as you can
see here the uh there are multiple value
of V1 for the same angle of attack which
means that effectively the out encoder
is failing it cannot compress the
solutions at the angle of attack because
there is the need of an additional
degree of Freedom that I'm not allowing
the out CER to have and so this again in
terms of interpretability is a perfect
example of what is um the limit uh of
what you can compress and you can
interpret that that limit very
effectively now um the the other case
that that is interesting is to see what
happens in the case where you have
unsteady behavior and again this is the
same curve I was showing you before the
lift in this case I'm I'm changing
sinusoidally the angle of attack so
there is a cycle that uh that we obtain
for the lift coefficient and this cycle
all all
shows some interesting differences
between the airs that have um low
thickness 0012 and 0014 the th airfall
compared to the th airs the th airs you
see have a very smooth curve the red and
green whereas the black and blue have
sort of these U unsteady Behavior this
more complex behavior that has to do
with the physics of the problem which is
the U presence of a a Vortex separation
at the Leading Edge for Te Air Force and
not and the same thing not present for
for Te Air Force well if we look at
latent variables in this case we sort of
see a similar Trend in the sense that um
the the these are now uh um the plots of
V1 with respect to V3 and V1 with
respect to V2 so it's a p equal three AO
encoder but as you can see the green and
the red actually have relatively
simple curves that that are shown here I
mean these are trajectory obvious in
three in in three dimensions
whereas the blue and the black have a
very very different behavior for a a
certain uh component of the cycle that
corresponds to that that separation so
once again the outon quer is actually
representing the the physics of these
different aold differently simply by
trying to compress that information and
this is again sort of an automatic
result of of the compression strategy
rather than something that we are
imposing or we are uh exposing the out
encoder directly
uh now just to conclude this part this
is again uh just to illustrate that is a
a very effective way of actually
reconstructing geometries and and
reconstructing solution in this case the
cost of one reconstruction is a fraction
of a of a uh of a second um on a on a
single GPU compared to many hours uh on
uh uh on uh uh on you know of the
original calculation so this is
effectively achieving what we want which
which is a a very fast methodology to
compress these
Solutions but now uh one other one
aspect that I want to point out which is
a little bit different than the
classical out encoders is the way we
actually perform in the training um so
the the process is called or at least we
called it the sequential training
process where the idea is that we always
build a sequence of Auto encoder we
start with with P equal one uh
onedimensional uh latent space and then
we we increase the size uh partly to
check the convergence we want to know
what is the minimum size of out encoders
that will give you a good convergence
from a from a a loss perspective but
also good accuracy but the idea that we
had was that rather than discarding the
information of the the uh smaller outen
coders as we increase the lat in space
we actually want to keep that
information in the spirit of uh what we
do for example with singular value DEC
composition which affect effectively
allows us to build uh formally
orthogonal latent spaces right each each
latent dimension in that case the
singular values are corresponding to an
orthogonal decomposition uh um of of the
Matrix itself now in this case we cannot
do exactly the same because of the
linearity but we are actually using the
low order latent space to condition the
variables in the I order latent space so
that there is a sort of a consistent
consistency between latent spaces of
different dimension and uh this from a
practical perspective helps for a
convergence um perspective but also
allows us to build sort of an
understanding a a a a hierarchical
understanding of what's happening to to
the latent spaces and to the information
that we're adding into into the latent
uh latent
spaces um this also allows us to do a
comparison a direct comparison between
uh what we do with SVD and what we do
with these out encoders so um for
example in this case I'm showing you uh
what happens if we do SVD versus an out
encoder for the same uh for a for a
similar data set of of airf um and this
shows again that from a linear
perspective you get a good compression
but the latent space is actually not
very well organized you see actually
that um some of the uh red uh here or
the the dark red actually uh wrap around
the others these are colored with the
with different airs and and so we are
expecting that it's difficult to
actually interpolate between solution in
the linear setting whereas It's
relatively easy to do it in the in the
nonlinear case in the out encoder and
more importantly um if we actually look
at the the ability to compress uh the
solutions the out encoder is a very
effective in compression in compressing
the the data set already with a size of
two P equal 2 whereas the SVD require a
much much larger size to get to similar
compression quality and this is actually
measured in this case with explained
variance but you can take other metrics
and and show that effectively the
nonlinearity in the outen coder really
uh Fosters this compression because some
of the rank of these data sets is not
very low is not as low as as we would
like it to be so the the linear
compression is not are not as
effective okay let me switch gear and
talk about the uncertainty
quantification part which is the last
part part that that we focused on which
is sort of driving this this idea of
building confidence so the the first
thing I want to say is that we have
uncertainty also in in physics based
calculations this uncertainty can be
driven by real uncertainty what I call
external uncertainty on the physical
inputs for example if we don't know the
geometry very accurately of the problem
of interest and uh there is uncertainty
due to internal sources this have to do
with for example modeling assumptions
that we make in this model and the the
way we approach uh the uncertainty in
this setting is to actually uh uh
perform typically an ensemble of
simulations so rather than one
simulation we perform a a large number
of simulations typically and by U
constructing uh either uh probability
distributions on those simulations or
perhaps more sophisticated construction
we can actually build uh probability um
uh or probabilistic uh estimation of the
quantity of Interest so that we can
build uh confidence intervals now for
for the out encoders we have a similar
or in general machine learning we have a
similar setting where we have external
uncertainties exactly in the same way
that affect physical inputs and then we
have internal uncertainty which have to
do with modeling assumptions which in
this case for example can be the type of
architecture we're using the number of
convolutional layers we're using and so
on but in addition to what we had before
we now have the data the learning data
actually is a major source of
uncertainty because we don't know how
much data we need we don't know for
example um if we cover the entire space
of of uh uh data set that we need to
actually make the prediction of interest
and so the the question becomes how can
we actually quantify the uncertainty in
this setting and in a very similar way
to what we do in physics models we
actually build an ensemble of outen
coders so what we do is that we
typically train um many many out
encoders uh that have different
architecture and so on on the same data
sets and then we try to build
probabilistic information of the output
so let me give you um a summary of what
we actually do so in this case uh we
built a data set again with very few
cases about 30 um but with something
very intentional that was built into the
data set which is the idea that we want
to do prediction both in an extrapolar
context so for example for angle of
attack Beyond 30° so we don't have data
in that setting but we also left a gap
intentionally in in a range of angle of
attacks to see what happens with sort of
an interpolative Behavior but in the
absence of
data um the the type of uncertainty we
consider are typically geometry for the
external uncertainty for the internal
uncertainty everything that has to do
with the architecture of the network the
parameters in the network and the data
that we're using so for example how much
data that we have in the in the in the
training set as well and then the the
basic idea as I mentioned is to train an
ensemble of out encoders and then build
probability distribution on the outcomes
all these uh emble
Set uh and and just to show you directly
what the answer is this is sort of the
the final the you know one of the
solutions that we obtain um again is
reported in terms of the lift
coefficient for one of the airs what
your what I'm showing you here is the
the true prediction or the the the
ground truth is the r is the red line
here um the black line is the mean of
the The Ensemble of the outen coders and
the the the blue plot the blue range is
actually the confidence interval that we
obtain is also reported here in terms of
the uh size of the confidence interval
so in this case low confidence interval
um so small size of the confidence
interval means high confidence in the
results and what you can see as expected
is that we have a large uh confidence
interval so low confidence in general in
the region of extrapolation Beyond 30°
as you can see the prediction gets uh
low and lower confidence as we as we
move out but also similarly a very large
confidence interval so very low
confidence interpretation in these
interpolatory regions that sort of again
illustrates how important it is to sort
of carefully construct data sets if we
want to do predictions with with the
with confidence now the the advantage of
this meod is that you know in addition
to to sort of a a global metric like
this we can actually uh also check the
importance of each component of the uh
out encoder that we built so for example
the effect of adding convolutional layer
the effect of adding or reducing the the
number of uh um connecting uh uh neurons
in the in the connected layers or the
size and the quality of the training
sets now in this particular case the the
main takeaway is that the effect of the
lack of data within the in Interpol
region or the extrapolate region is the
dominant one but there are a lot of
other things that you can learn in cases
in the situations where instead you have
sufficient amount of data you can see
how at a certain level the the amount of
data is sufficient that you get better
and better confidence in in general in
the prediction as you um um uh increase
the number of data um the the other
thing I wanted to point out is that we
have used the a we have not used a
convolutional uh sorry a variational out
encoder because we wanted to effectively
build probabilistic information for the
latent space directly and because we
built uh hundreds of outo encoders that
have all the same size of the latent
space then we can build for example the
um statistics in this case the average
and the standard deviation of the latent
space variables and again this represent
again the pr Ence of lack of data and
and uh um and clearly identify regions
where we can actually uh go back and
improve our data set so that we can
improve the confidence of the results so
the idea is that this is a process that
can be done repeatedly to get more and
more confidence in the
results and so the the um we we also
perform simulations where we actually
introduce an external uncertainty so for
example the geometry and we compare the
uncertainty induced by that that uh
uncertain geometry either through
physics simulation or through these uh
um out encoders and the results are very
consistent so what we see is that um the
main the the uncertainty due to the
geometry which is reported in this case
with the with dash line in terms of
confidence is actually very good there
is very little little uncertainty
induced by the geometry and this
uncertainty is actually capture
correctly both uh through the out
encoder and through actual simulations
through the the the simul the the direct
cfd simulations but this uncertainty is
actually much smaller than the
uncertainty induced by the um
architecture of the outo encoder and so
you see the BL the the blue curve which
is the total uncertainty and so this
again tells you that in this particular
case the the most important um uh source
of uncertainty is the data set and you
need to train it out outon coder in a in
a more comprehensive way to get to get
better confidence in the predictions but
but you see able to uh compare uh
compare
both um so the the uh what I showed you
is sort of an approach to build a data
driven model with small data set in a
principal way so carefully uh selecting
and proceeding through steps and and
this shows that effectively are these
out encoder uh out encoders are very uh
effective compressing um compressing
tools uh again this is consistent with
what is available in the literature um
and the the difference here is the idea
that using the terministic out encoders
so not variational out encoders helps
you separating the sources of
uncertainty because you can identify now
uncertainty both in the latent variables
so probabilistic representation of those
but also directly separating for example
the effect of the architecture um and in
this case at least in our setting in our
uh range the limited data set is the
most critical source of uncertainty um
there is a lot of work that is currently
goinging I'm not going to give you too
much detail I just want to mention that
we are working both on three-dimensional
geometries uh more complex geometry we
are very interested in multifidelity and
there is a a very nice um extension to
this work that that we're completing
right now that addresses multifidelity
and then effectively the the real time
Computing for doing for doing Maneuvers
is is what is our ultimate goals um and
um uh maybe the one thing I'm I'm going
to share with you is um how we are doing
the multifidelity which is perhaps the
most interesting part um so the basic
idea of the multifidelity is that rather
than um uh uh taking advantage of of low
Fidelity data set to add to the to the
solutions um can be effectively very
useful and the way we are doing it
through um the the same concept of
sequential training so what we are doing
is that we are training the first out
encoder with for example nonviscous
solution all or solution of this problem
and this gives us an outon code that
effectively can reproduce the solution
and then we are adding additional uh
data um and you know for example rant
data viscus calculations and we are
increasing corresponding in the the the
latent space but by conditioning so that
we are still representing the the uh
effect of the oler solution directly the
in the case and what we see is that for
low angle of attack so in the regions
where we don't expect a lot of um uh lot
of inaccuracy given by the Aller
solution we actually have the fact that
the latent space is actually consistent
in the in the two cases but the added
variables effectively um are
representing the the viscosity the
effect of viscosity and so the idea is
that we can separate very neatly very
clearly the effects of um low Fidelity
versus I Fidelity directly by
conditioning the latent space and this
is work in progress but I think is very
promising especially for complex
application where building databases of
I Fidelity can be uh quite daunting and
quite
complex okay I'll I'll stop here I have
some references here um but again I'm
happy to to answer question and also
connect afterwards if you have if you
have more information and I do want to
acknowledge etor s who is a who was a um
PhD student at University of napl that
spent some time with me here on campus
at Sanford and continues to work on on
this top
um and and both the architecture and the
application in
aerodynamics okay um I I'll stop here so
thank you for for your attention and um
I'm happy to the questions thank you
thank you so much for the wonderful
wonderful talk Jan that was awesome um
we already have a two questions from
from in the chat uh box I can I can no
no I I just opened it I can see it do
you want me to start from there okay
yeah so start from the first question
from Maya yeah okay how does the method
handles noise in the input training of
testing data perhaps okay that's a great
question now um I should have said this
before we are targeting numerical
simulations for this so we haven't
effectively uh studied the effect of
imperfect measurements because again
we're are hoping that this is a method
to compress uh simulations at least the
way we designed it but one thing that we
did which is very interesting inter in
is that when we started the project we
started to work um because it's a
convolutional network with image images
uh in our inputs and images by virtue of
going you know translating between say a
cfd solution to um for example uh RGB
maps and going through Contour levels
introduced actually noise it's very
specific noise it's not you know random
noise but it is
and it is an approximation it turns out
that we notice that the latent spaces
are actually quite affected by simply
having you know for example a conversion
to RGB or a conversion into Contours
rather than row values of the inputs and
so what we found is that and this is
probably what you'll see when you have
noise so what happens is that the latent
space representations are not as clean
as the one that we have if you have
noise and so it might be more difficult
to interpret it especially in the in the
ssense of you know um enormous amount of
data so that that has been our our
experience at least and I imagine I
haven't done it with with actual
gaussian noise or or real noise but I
think the effect will be the same so the
the noise in the input will be directly
represented in the latent space in in
terms of clean lless and this is part of
the reason why convol why variational
outen coders tend to be popular in that
setting because you sort of account
immediately for that noise uh as I said
we wanted to be very clean in terms of
the inputs that we
generated okay how does the
computational cost hopefully I answer
the question um how does the
computational cost of the out encoder
compared to that of a run fluid
simulation of FL full um yeah I had I
maybe flashed this to quickly so for
steady
calculation um The Well unsteady
calculation the the the range the the
ratio of cost is uh many many order of
magnitude as as we as
one would expect um this action
increases even more these are two-
dimensional cases as you go through
three-dimensional cases and perhaps try
to capture even more sort of detailed
Solutions the expectation is that more
and more the the factor the multiplier
will be will be large uh obviously on
the other end if you're doing
two-dimensional steady perhaps course
simulations in runs the the the
differential is not that large but in
our examples it's still you know
multiple order of magnitude
and this is the cost of evaluation
obviously there is the training cost
which is you know added to to that but
if you're talking just about evaluation
for a new case obviously the multiplier
is many many
order I I think
the the Mark is asking about the
training cost okay the training cost so
the the training cost you know again uh
our strategy has been to use very uh
small data sets so we're talking about
less than 100 data sets and so the cost
is never larger than than you know few
hours uh on on typically on single gpus
we we did not really have to to go much
higher now we expect again as the
database increases not in terms of
number of cases but in terms of details
because now we're using perhaps
threedimensional data set and so on we
we are uh obviously seeing much uh
larger cost but still on single GPU
we're still talking about order of hours
not no more than that
thank you okay so uh how can you predict
two different values for the same angle
attack for noise up and now down motion
from the snapshot trading
um oh that I see I see that's a that's a
good question so um what we do is that
we we use batches and the batches
actually include uh three cases so we
typically have um a sort of a implicitly
we are giving a a Time variation in the
setting that that you know gives a
difference between say you know nose up
and nose down um so we're not formally
giving the Dynamics the full Dynamics
but we are capturing sort of
instantaneously if you like a DDT uh a
changing time um of of the actual
solution so that has been uh that has
been a a you know one one idea obviously
that we we were trying to pursue is to
build Dynamic models in the latent space
um but rather than providing full
information about trajectory we wanted
to just give uh sort of bursts just very
very short time duration for the for the
batches and and that seems to be at
least for this case is sufficient now um
I can anticipate that you know this is I
should mention this uh this problem in
this problem there is an extra degree of
Freedom which is the frequency uh in
time so the What's called the reduced
frequency right is you know it's not
only a range of angle of attack is how
quickly you're going through those angle
of attack so everything that we've done
here is fixing that frequency so that we
don't have an additional degree of
freedom but if you do have that
additional degree of Freedom our
expectation is that you need to provide
more information you need to provide
some sort of uh rate of change of angle
of attack with time to be able to
actually do the prediction in this case
that was fixed and so we um we sort of
assume that that was sort of
known hopefully that anwers your
question um oh wow there are a lot of
questions okay lost lost track where am
I but Jo next question is by Joel okay U
just learning about but from what I seen
variational more ideal for Generation
does a basic will will here du to the
more Nar yes absolutely so the the basic
idea here is that we have um a very
clean data set so we don't have noise
and and so this in this way the
variational auto encoder um does not
really provide a lot of advantages in
this
case thing that is important that we
didn't want to assume um a probabilistic
description say Gan model or mixture of
gence and so on in the latest space
because we wanted to inform that through
our emble of a coders so our idea is
that you know the the probabilistic
information with space come from the
combination of all these uh Ensemble or
all these outo coders in The Ensemble
rather than through an anets on the
probabilistic model for the for the
Laten variables hopefully that answers
the
question next one is by
khid uh can you please explain a little
about sequential training for the multi
do we train the L data with
and yes uh exactly so what we do is that
we uh Train by using the low Fidelity in
this case low Fidelity means inv visit
non viscosity High Fidelity means with
viscosity but you can imagine a
different setting but the basic idea is
that we train first on the low
Fidelity and then what we do is that we
add to this low Fidelity cases di
Fidelity so we have for each um you know
we we have um the the two data sets sort
of combined together okay and then what
we do is that we condition the first
variables in the latent space using the
previous results and we build basically
representation of the you know full data
set now the the key here is that we
tried both by making each case so each
time we have an IID case the question is
if we need to have a low Fidelity
corresponding or not and it turns
actually actually for at least for this
problem that was not that critical even
if we don't have a corresponding low
Fidelity the the two latent spaces you
know can be combined in a very clean way
without without too much trouble but I
expect in some other situation you will
need to be able to differentiate between
low Fidelity and I Fidelity and discard
the low Fidelity cases whenever you have
an i Fidelity so that you you Neely sort
of distinguish the two kind of
information at least for the examples I
gave you that was not necessary but as I
said that's work in progress so we'll
see a little bit more as we expand the
scope of of some of those
analysis and and and you're right I
think the challenge is how complex is
the physics that you're adding or
another way to say it is how good the L
Fidelity modeling that you're using is
because if the LA Fidelity modeling is
very inaccurate and very uh unable to
reproduce some of the features then it's
very likely that the conditioning is is
really not very helpful because you are
not you know not able to use much of the
information from the roid so I I think
the challenge there is to understand
from looking at the latent space
especially in the low Fidelity and in
the mix space sort of the the combined
space if that information is actually
interpretable that will give you a set
of uh at least some confidence in the
outcomes right if there is no real
connection between the two then likely
what this means is that your low
Fidelity model is not a very good
representation very useful
representation for the for the combined
for the physical
problem okay uh let's see where am I uh
Chris uh next is Chris yes with your
metal multi for nois experimental data
for instance could you add a new latent
parameter uh but have it to be a
variational latent parameter and keep
the
real oh that's an interesting idea that
there is no reason not to um in fact uh
one of the things you can do is that you
can actually build a a um variational
Auto
encoder but where you condition for the
first variables you condition the the
variance to be zero and so naturally it
will be sort of variational only for the
final set set of variables right so the
same ideas you can definitely use it we
haven't tried it I I don't know if it
will be easy or not but at least
conceptually yes you can definitely do
that and it will be actually very
interesting to try um because as you say
there are some additional you know now
now what I said before we don't want to
use you know variational out inorder
because our data set is clean now
obviously multi that's not the case
anymore right you the data set is not
really clean because the low Fidelity
cases have errors with respect to the
High Fidelity cases that are not really
captured in the inputs and so the
variational the additional the
variational V the the the variance in
the latent space might actually help
with that so it's it's a really good
idea in fact maybe we should talk more
about that afterwards if you if you're
interested
um so I copied the Wesley's questions oh
okay the plot show are clcd polars if
the integr equality is the goal would
the training benefit of worson from oh
great question yeah um the the reason
I'm so I would the
let's say I don't know we tried
originally to build out encoders with
only the the um integrated quantities in
mind um and as you can imagine it's
relatively easy to do that um but what
we wanted to do here instead is to
reconstruct the flow fields and we are
extracting the lift and Drug from the
flow fields from the actual pressure
that is that is reconstructed so this is
effectively a harder problem because we
are not you know con straining the the
pressure Distribution on the airf or the
integrated quantities um but the reason
why we want to do this is because again
remember this is a a process of
compression of those flow Fields so we
don't know exactly how these flow fields
are going to be used and so we don't
want to limit oursel to just the the
aerodynamic coefficients we just want to
reconstruct typically the velocity
fields and so for for us the goal was to
reconstruct the fields we are just using
the lift and the drag as a as a way to
summarize it
um what difference does the training
process have for 3D unsteady turbulent
flow um so at least in our project what
we are doing thre dimensionality doesn't
change anything obviously the complexity
of the geometry the size of the data set
that's fair uh but you know there is
nothing that that changes um unsteady
per se is not a problem as I mentioned
as long as these are um reasonably well
um uh described uh flow field in terms
of times and data sets in terms of times
I think we can we can handle it
turbulence is a different story in the
sense that if you're interested in the
time varying behavior of a turbulent
flow so the
instantaneous I would argue that
probably the amount of data required is
way more than what we are thinking here
so what we are doing here is to try to
represent the statistics of a turbulent
flow so say a time average solution of a
turbulent flow uh and in that sense I
think the solutions are expected to be
smooth changing smoothly on a on a large
time scale and so we're expecting that
to be possible even in a more complex
turb flow say computed through a a larg
simulation for example but we're not I
mean at least at this point these
methods are not targeting the
instantaneous variation of a turbulent
of a turbulent flow that will be at
least in terms of complexity and size
really Beyond sort of the scope of what
we trying to do and there are obviously
you know both in the labs and and around
are a lot of efforts in that direction
and and you will see easily that you
know going to these low dimensional
latent spaces is really not practical
for for those cases the Dynamics we know
the Dynamics in a turbulent flow are
much much higher Dimension than than two
and three so the whole scope of of the
problem will
change okay well I I think that was the
that was it from the chat room but is
there any question from audience who
wants to unmute yourself and then ask
question
questions if there are please do
so well I guess we uh we don't have um
audience with the question who wants to
unmute um well then well thank you so
much for the wonderful presentations and
Q&A session it was it was awesome and
very smooth well thank you very much
appreciate it and thank you again for
the invitation and for the attention
thanks that's awesome um Jan would you
mind sharing the the slide with me uh
sure no no problem I'll send it to you
okay awesome well thank you for the one